Vanessa Hudgens is ready for high school
musical for I love musicals Petey spoke
with the 27 year old actress at the NBC
up fronts on Monday where she revealed
she still finds herself belting out the
classic tunes from the first three High
School Musical movies sometimes someone
will be like we're all in this together
and I'm like but oh it just is it's like
reflexes
and Hudgens couldn't be more excited for
a new cast of characters to take over
the franchise being able to do musicals
is such a dream of mine and the fact
that they're keeping that alive and
bringing it to a new generation I think
is really wonderful she might still
reminisce about high school from time to
time but the actress is on a new
exciting project starring an NBC's new
DC Comics comedy powerless 15 seconds on
the clock
why is powerless the number one show
that you need to tune into it's going to
make you laugh it's going to make you
cry everyone is amazing and hysterical
there are awesome superheroes and it's a
office comedy which is always the best
you get knocked down but you will get up
again all I guess together
you